Christmas is calling –
auf der Oxford Street in London.
Die Einkaufsmeile läutet die
Weihnachtssaison ein.
Für viele der Startschuss zum Dekorieren –
aber welcher Schmuck ist dieses Jahr
besonders angesagt?
Eines der großen Trendthemen:
„Weihnachtsrock“.
Rock 'n' Roll gehört diesen Winter nicht nur
auf die Ohren, sondern auch an den Baum.
Es dreht sich alles um Rock 'n' Roll.
Glitzer, Funkeln und Metallic –
für eine dekadente Party
mit Familie und Freunden.
Wir waren fasziniert von den
verschiedenen Materialien
und wie viel Spaß man mit
dem Thema haben kann.
Mit Samt und Pailletten werden
auch die traditionellen
Weihnachtsstrümpfe Teil der
Edelrock-Deko.
Silber und Gold, aber vor allem
Schwarz ist besonders angesagt –
Hauptsache, es rockt.
Bei diesem Trend mitzumachen:
Das lässt sich auch Superstar
Prince nicht nehmen.
Wichtig für Rock'n'Roll-Weihnachtslichter
sind die Farben.
Ich glaube, wir haben uns
viele Jahre nicht getraut,
den Retro-Look mit bunten
Lichtern zu kombinieren.
Aber dieses Jahr ist die
richtige Zeit dafür.
Wer dezente Zurückhaltung
langweilig findet,
kann mit dem Rock 'n' Roll-Trend diese
Weihnachten nicht falsch liegen.
Weniger laut und knallig aber mindestens
genauso schillernd und ausgefallen
ist dieser besonders schmackhafte
Trend.
Dieses Jahr sind wir vom Thema
Essen begeistert.
Es gibt dem Weihnachtsbaum
einen verspielten Touch:
Wir haben zum Beispiel Popcorn,
Erdbeer-Körbchen, Bagels, oder
Salz-und-Pfeffer-Weihnachtsschmuck.
In Großbritannien sind Nahrungsmittel
als Design-Trend schon länger
zu beobachten, aber jetzt erobern
sie auch den Weihnachtsbaum.
Also nicht nur beim weihnachtlichen
Festmahl, sondern auch bei der Dekoration
ist Schlemmen angesagt
Die Farbauswahl spielt dabei keine Rolle –
bunt und lecker muss der
Weihnachtsbaum aussehen.
Ich liebe die Avocado. Jeder liebt doch,
Avocado zu essen.
Und ich denke, als Deko ist sie ein nettes,
lustiges Geschenk.
Sie ist schön und funkelt
und sieht neben dem anderen
Weihnachtsschmuck hübsch aus.
Wem das zu außergewöhnlich ist,
der kann sich mit klassischer
Weihnachtsdekoration ein gemütliches
Zuhause zaubern.
Ein Wohlfühl-Ambiente verspricht
der Trend
mit dem schönen Namen
„Midnight Elegance“.
Hier muss man einiges beachten.
Es geht darum, ein luxuriöses Zuhause
zu schaffen, mit kräftigen Farben,
schönen Oberflächen,
Metallelementen und Glas.
So bringen Sie Glanz und Funkeln
auf Ihren Tisch,
an Ihren Weihnachtsbaum und
in Ihr ganzes Zuhause.
Mit viel Gold, Glas und Blau wird
diese Festtafel ein Hingucker.
Ganz im Trend ist natürlich auch die Deko
auf der Oxford Street.
Mit fast 2000 Weihnachtskugeln wird sie
zum wahren Winterwunderland.
Aber ist es nicht etwas zu früh, um die
Weihnachtsbeleuchtung einzuschalten?
Es ist etwas früh, aber hey,
Weihnachten ist toll.
Jeder liebt Weihnachten.
Also warum nicht?
Ich denke, es ist schön, dass Sie jetzt
schon die Lichter anschalten,
das bringt Menschen zusammen, es ist
festlich und weckt die Vorfreude.
Es bringt alle in Stimmung
und erinnert daran,
dass Weihnachten vor der Tür steht.
Die Gesichter meiner Kinder zu sehen,
wie sie beim Lichtereinschalten strahlen,
das war toll für mich.
Und je früher die Weihnachtszeit
eingeläutet wird, desto länger
kann man sich in Sachen Dekoration
schließlich ausleben.